hello glamour readers and the riot Club
fans we are live in London with the cost
of the riot club I'm with Douglas booth
Holliday Grainger Sam Claflin Jessica
brown Findlay and max irons and I'm
going to be asking them the questions
that you've all been sending in for the
last few days so here we go the first
question we've got is for all of you and
it's from madness or Nicks Herondale
could or could not be the actual madness
they say this is the most twisted movie
trailer
I have ever seen what was it like
playing these intense characters for the
boys really and yeah well it yeah it was
enjoyable actually I definitely had a
lot of fun playing a darker character
for a change and I think once you kind
of go over the hurdle of actually
understanding why they were the way they
were
it was interesting kind of seeing how
the other half live well you know and
you know it's sort of select few from
the other half but no it was it was
really enjoyable there were some days
that were pretty unpleasant because
everyone's there soap everyone's so good
that uh it sort of gets inside you what
sort of infects you the subject matter
you felt dirty when you went home if I
felt like wash your hands I think the
girls a bit creeped out they were just
like yes you'll seem like you kind of
still like each other so just about
force yeah yeah the next question is
from Amy and it's for Sam what's the
moral of this film and the story it
tells Oh God so please go ah Doug was
saying something really interesting
about I think everyone's going to take a
different you know learn something new
for me personally it wasn't like a
political choice dinner on me I didn't
do this for the political aspects of it
what I really found interesting was the
kind of the social side of it in the
sense of not only was there a great cast
becoming attached but it was just an
insight into a world that I wasn't
familiar with personally so I think
that's the moral of the story I said
tough never gonna get rid of injustice
or people don't have empathy for other
people I think you come out this film
wanting the whole world to be a little
bit more empathic my gosh thanks yeah
you can do that all the way through the
Dane I actually quite agree with myself
warned about sticking it being too
sticking to second to your principles
everyone that doesn't stick to their own
principles in the film this guy an
example like ends up down there and
everyone that does sync to the
principles yes ends up hop there even if
you don't whatever don't agree ah yeah
the next one is for all of you from
Gemma and did any of you see the play
that the riot club is adapted from and
do you think the film is a loyal
adaptation if you have I saw the play
and I think I mean it the thing about
the players it's M one room so you've
got to get over that hurdle for the film
and what's amazing is that it really it
gives you an opportunity to go and find
out who these characters are outside of
that room I mean give give it more
context and also get to know these
people and that's what's interesting you
sort of in a way I mean the first half
the film it's like quite funny and it
was very funny and you'll see that the
audience will laugh and the in the
cinemas like Aaron in cinemas quite
relaxed and then there's a point where
everyone starts feeling guilty about
laughing and then people start feeling
quite affected by what's happening so I
think that's that's that's gained by
being able to kind of really fall for
these character the beginning and sort
of see them in their everyday life and
then take them into the room where we
play out the kind of that big dinner
scene yeah so that's that's why I think
so it is loyal but it's the same writer
Laura wait so it's just it's opened up
and actually these these people this
these female characters were added and
Mail these females
he's like Holly got things like Holly's
The Hollies part was written for the
film was written for me you talk about
that she's really a part of the movies
you know you take you take kind of the
audience on that journey don't you
really you're getting it's just a look
Lauren and Ray it's the got the women in
the movie aren't there and characters
that offer another viewpoint in another
standpoint these guys and you kind of I
think there
the guys are sort of the 1% of society
and I think most people in society can
identify with the women the female
characters I think was good about the
movies all the female characters are
like true representations of
actual work and until you kind of feel
like they take you on the journey and
the next question is from Ezra and it's
so Jessica
what were your favorite moments on set I
don't know brilliant and favorite
moments on set this is really immature
but I am so I'm gonna go with it there
was a day where and oh my god I love
potatoes just became to me the funniest
thing I'd ever heard he loved a roast
potato and I just couldn't get over how
funny that was and I told that story to
people who weren't there and it hasn't
gone down well so I hope they'll see the
film and their amazing thing and they'll
love but I was just a huge knife in
Toronto yeah people laughing with you
gesture okay bye okay everyone's
laughing at home yeah in the movie four
people didn't know that if the potato is
aligned someone says in the film and
fellas in play yeah no I don't think I
made a contato ticket anything that was
the moral of the story
that was my man or maybe a character
really meant was oh my god I really
fancy you
yes came I saw a cool the next question
is from Petey scoop
he said the boys are all very dapper in
this film and this is a question for all
of you what is the most stylish item
that you own Beauty scope hmm go right
to left or left to right I've got quite
a hat recently I used to feel about hats
how I feel about cigars you have to be
over a certain age to wear a hat but in
fact I've been brought round so I have a
rather nice hat by like one little face
partly was about five I wouldn't leave
the house that huh yeah good yeah how do
you earn a lot of Hearts I feel like a
spider oh yeah um uh I'm not very silent
but I do this is for me a little like I
never
I have a little like old 1920s wedding
band thing that's made of wax and the
flowers or waxy and I took off the veil
because that was too much
day to day wear and I wear it all the
time when I wear it I feel amazing oh my
god you're the coolest thing that I own
[Music]
laser which is where most stylists thing
that is blazer to you thank you so much
mm-hmm yeah you guys we got anything
he's your she's my Shay's oh did you say
women say but you see um I'm sorry I did
want me to tell your answer what is your
most stylish thing um I don't feel
particularly stylish oh I just looked at
my wardrobe the other day I just got all
my clothes hanging up on open rails it's
all black I'm the same yeah yeah yeah
this is great but I know I don't know I
I'm not sure my most stylish item I
might be here for a while I have I don't
know my fellow my favorites is like my
trust I have a big leather jacket which
is too hot to wear right now but that's
my favorite it's it's like release rate
sunglasses always feel stylish and
person mrs. Chanel sunglasses
hmm you can wear anything in them and
yeah oh you're getting everything great
and the next one is from mystique I
don't know is that again a little me
yesterday my retro bands all of them um
this is for all of you if you can
describe your character in three words
what would they be
he's really hard quite how quite high
which I'm sorry um Stan you're lying a
young naive
foolish mm-hmm
kind frustrated and waitress I'm so
sorry Lori she's very calm I'm saying
frustrated ambitious and introvert right
oh so many words so many words said at
the time um I'd say strong but also
naive that's that's four words
uh wrong nice and nothing suave lush and
malicious oh oh oh ouch I like it
the next question is from Kerala who
says power can be a dangerous tool do
you think it's the same for fame I think
I've been going corrupt in the way that
power can corrupt something but oh but
also I think I mean if you look at some
of these people that on Twitter have
more more followers than any sort of any
paper has a readership or any website
has I mean that's a lot of savvy but has
more than yeah more than segment well
yeah of course yeah I know but in like
any paper The Guardian The Sunday Times
the glamour even the Daily Mail website
think has it yeah so that's a lot of
power to yield but then what's even
scarier is someone like Rupert Murdoch
who who controls many many things more
more than just a paper he owns many
papers many news channel so yeah it's a
scary thing especially when yeah when
they're in bed with the next question is
actually a few numbers from a Megan what
was it like playing more of a bad boy in
this movie compared to other roles
you've had yeah it was fun
it was really good fun I mean it's it's
it's different and it's as Sam was
saying is it's okay
sorry Benson yeah it was yeah no it was
it was yeah it was difficult it was
difficult but challenged but fun and
yeah I mean it it it's a bad boy but it
also goes to such dark places in this
movie that sometimes it feels
uncomfortable but I I yeah it was it was
a great challenge
um the next question is for Jessica from
Callie who says what is your favorite
movie or TV show um mmm
right now I'm just watching back
obviously right um but I can't stop
watching Modern Family
I love it and um much on the other day
when Candice does this hilarious fall
and I love I love a funny for I know
that's really obvious but someone just
falling out frame makes me I was gone
for about ten minutes you know what's
great for that as well the Chuckle
brothers
oh but me scared me and they were really
annoying they couldn't get it right man
come on baby you must have looked sorry
you know some of us do happen huh yeah
the next question is for max from Rose
rose would like to know was it hard to
place yourself in the situation's you'll
get your character goes through or was
it fun um it was it was fun but but but
also uncomfortable um
yes in an uncomfortable world that
exists so sort of facing that reality
that there are people out there they get
up to this kind of thing and get away
with it made you fairly uncomfortable
and as I said earlier the boys are such
good actors that they are as they came
up there were as predatory in nasty yeah
yeah yeah um then I got questions from
Amelia for Sam did you really drink that
awful thing in the trailer yes yeah yes
he did
I remember saying that I wanted to
expire wanted to I remember that I
remember saying that I wanted to be and
I also want to do that the condom of
whiskey I was yeah let's do it let's do
it I want to feel what it's like I don't
think I would have remembered my lines
afterwards but um yeah
now I genuinely wanted to do that the
maggot the money strange I try anything
once jealous of something though got one
the next question is for all of you from
Amy um it's quite a serious one everyone
has been in situations where events
spiral out of control do you have any
advice for people who get into these
situations don't know I I don't think if
that happens if it actually spirals out
of control it's important to sort of
speak to someone that that can help you
out in every okay I mean we've all been
on much more minor circumstances and the
best thing to do is always to go and
like speak to someone that can help you
and there's you know that if you're if
you're if you're younger than an adult
your parent yeah it's very important
yeah and I say it's in poor mean things
do happen and and and you must always
never too late it's never too late to
try and stop it even have a bad you
think it's got or have a however deep in
deep you are with something you there's
always always a chance to get out and
people will always understand peer
pressure is a dangerous thing I mean I
think we all experience somewhat you
know like if I mean for example what
miles is character kinda gets roped into
that sort of false sense of security
when Lauren arrives and the you know you
kind of put under pressure you don't
really know how to answer in any given
moment but like your friends won't force
you to do something you don't want to do
so I think that avoid it if you can or
like Doug sort of you know seek advice
or seek a real friend yeah thank you and
the next question is from hutch away for
Sam I'm that's your wife your character
is really snobby is there anyone who
influenced how you played your character
I only had to look at the other actors
is it's a question we kind of get asked
as actors quite a lot who inspired you
who did you base this character on so so
often people have an immediate answer
for our performance or an actor that
they bought you know a politician or
whatever I definitely looked at some
politicians for for some sort of accent
advice ideas but
really you know it was an original
character and I'm an actor and I you
know I wanted to create something that
was new and I didn't want to do
something that was a mimicry of someone
else or preview an impersonation of a
previous performance so I kind of I took
bits and bobs from all over the place
really I'm an observer and also Laura
where did such a good job of making
these no yes three-dimensional image we
had their backstories we had everything
provided to us there
there's nothing cliche or weakly formed
you get to see a paper which you said
your uncle does this you know something
we'd never even yeah amazing it was that
was really useful you know yeah and the
next question is from Carrie for all of
you are there any particularly amusing
university experiences you had you would
like to share I went to drama schools
it's slightly different to the
University feel that we're all there for
the same reason if you know I mean but
me and my friends within like the first
few weeks at drama school we dressed up
as lifeguards and roamed the streets of
London but well I say we dressed up as
lifeguards you know we basically wore
red boxer shorts and desktops and it was
like I think it was November so it's
very cold but you know it was and that
was like a three-day weekend if you know
what I'm saying it was I don't remember
sleeping much and I remember going to
school a nine o'clock on the Monday
morning feeling a little worse for wear
but I you know I didn't rip be any
landlords up or probably get rationally
rooms I I'd this weekend at university I
wasn't lucky enough because I was
working since I was 16 but I always
tried to go and visit my friends Union
again went down how crazy weekends and
going to do what with all the house
nights and stuff here what are you Greg
I'm not I just I
oh goody two-shoes I was a bit for goody
two-shoes uh-huh
I was at uni though I run the cops and
robbers Polly right uh of course I went
to the Robo strike address in a mask I
sort of lived in the library two o'clock
in the morning because I was too busy
working during the day on filming jobs I
was such a geek if you go did you do
Union I did Union I'm filming at same
time and I lived like I just didn't
sleep lived on Pro Plus I went to art
school so everyone was very subversive
and I was like Hello I didn't really
know what to do with myself so it took
me about a year to make to do anything
really but me and my best mate Emily
used to talk about what everyone else is
doing and while we sat our flat in
Kentish Town which we picked because it
had Harry Potter wallpaper in the toilet
and and drank Rosie I am men absolute
insanity crazy